well whatever happened to a
multi-billion dollar plan to siphon
groundwater from rural Nevada officially
it's off the table but the Coalition of
citizens who fought against it say they
expect the so-called water grab to rise
from the grave 8 news now Chief
investigator George Knapp says there's a
large clue that proves the plan is not
dead after all George yeah to paraphrase
Mark Twain reports of its death have
been greatly exaggerated snwa no longer
has the rural groundwater plan on the
front burner but it also hasn't pulled
the plug its ongoing interest can be
measured in cows and sheep and alfalfa
the Great Basin National Park the crown
jewel of Nevada's public lands is one of
the special places that could have been
jeopardized by the Southern Nevada water
Authority's ambitious groundwater plan
so it seemed an appropriate backdrop for
what was called a victory party you know
how did we get here 30 years of feisty
the Coalition that gathered in tiny
Baker Nevada is an amalgam of unlikely
bedfellows Urban liberals and Rural
conservatives ranchers and
environmentalists cowboys and Indians
they set aside differences to oppose an
audacious plan that would siphon
billions of gallons of groundwater from
Eastern Nevada aquifers and send it via
a 300 mile long pipeline to Thirsty Las
Vegas the Water Authority was willing to
spend 15 billion dollars maybe more to
build the pipeline system a plan backed
by Nevada's most powerful forces casinos
and developers opponents were told
resistance was futile that perception
was wrong and
inevitability
is
is a perception not a reality snwa has
spent in excess of 100 million public
dollars on the project records we
obtained show the public is still paying
for a long list of high-priced law firms
PR companies and lobbyists hired in part
to overcome opposition to the water grab
but scientific studies showed that
sucking an ocean of groundwater from the
rural counties could in effect create a
vast Dead Zone in Nevada a loan attorney
Simeon herskovitz prevailed again and
again in state and federal courts and
their entire case was built on
misdirection and misrepresentation of
fundamental questions of fact law and
policy but anytime anyone looked at the
very Elementary policy fundamentals of
Nevada water law you could see that this
is not permitted to take water that
doesn't exist after multiple defeats in
court snwa formally pulled the pipeline
plan off the table and withdrew its
claims to Rural Water but no one in the
opposition thinks the fight is over they
point to one glaring fact snwa still
owns and operates a vast ranching Empire
in the targeted area water agencies paid
close to 80 million dollars to buy seven
large ranches the ranches even have
their own lawyer and lobbyists paid with
public dollars they're growing Alfalfa
they're running cattle and they're
running sheep and you know they have
close to a million Acres of grazing
allotments up there and so I I don't
think that that the Southern Nevada
Water Authority remains
on you know AG operations 300 miles
north of here because they like the hay
business snwa declined to speak with us
on camera about why it is spending
public dollars to raise sheep and grow
hay hundreds of miles away from its
customers in its formal documents snwa
explains its northern resources are a
way to demonstrate improved agricultural
practices and livestock genetics and
husbandry and also to demonstrate
Financial efficiency those lessons seem
lost on the much smaller private
ranchers who say they're being ground to
dust by competing against a government
agency with Deep Pockets snwa has gone
after the grazing rights of ranchers
Hank bogler and Kenna glockner among
others forcing them into costly legal
fights that have dragged on for years it
makes absolutely no sense the amount of
money they're putting into those the
ranches and running them is not you know
is not economically feasible Gary perea
fought the water grab both as a White
Pine County Commissioner and also while
crisscrossing the state with his
stepfather the late Rancher Dean Baker
perea predicts agencies will try to
revive the water grab in the Nevada
legislature by crafting legislation that
might bypass water laws and they're
going to try and change the rules so to
make it easier for them to put their
water into the pipelines in the past
snwa use Scare Tactics to justify the
water graft there were numerous
predictions of disaster and economic
collapse unless Las Vegas could get the
Rural Water by 2013. that deadline came
and went nearly a decade ago and Las
Vegas is still thriving opponents say
extended drought is likely to be the new
excuse headlines about climate change
and images of the droplet water levels
of Lake Mead have already generated
statements about how snwa needs to leave
all of its options on the table when we
ask whether the rural pipeline is dead
or alive snwa told us quote it has been
deferred they deferred that project from
their Water Resource plan but they never
they they never said that we will never
do this ever ever
as mentioned snwa declined to speak to
us on camera but did provide written
answers to our questions about the
ranches that it owns you can read all of
that on our website 8newsnow.com you can
get there by scanning this QR code and
if you missed it we'll put it back up
for you again after Ted's forecast
George some of our viewers might
remember hearing the predictions of Doom
and Gloom if Las Vegas didn't get that
Rural Water how could they be so wrong
in those predictions well I think there
was a little bit of Hyperbole and
Showmanship in there I saved some
classic headlines from back in the bad
era of the water wars this is one from
it predicts a drought emergency likely
by 2005. here's the one you saw in that
story saying that Las Vegas growth will
you I did our water situation is better
than any other state
pack even though we are the driest state
in the country even though we get the
smallest amount of water from the
Colorado River and to this date we still
do not use our entire allocation from
the river those predictions prone to a
bit of hyperbole that's 2.0 George thank
you so much for that report